pierre on l'entend Xavier qui nous
parlait de la mobilisation à Poitiers
qui est une grande ville mais aussi dans
des communes comme Montmorillon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir de cette
mobilisation qui se fait pas seulement
dans les métropoles comme ces
traditionnellement le cas mais là il y a
beaucoup de mobilisation dans des villes
moyennes dans des petites villes avec
Xavier le rappeler des Français qui
manifestent pour la première fois oui
c'est vrai nous on a fait le choix
politique d'aller dans l'Aisne dans la
petite ville de Laon après avoir été
après que la manifestation de la du 19
janvier dernier a eu lieu à
Saint-Quentin c'est des petites villes
de France où la mobilisation est très
importante moi je le dis je l'ai déjà
dit ici je viens de Limousin des petites
villes comme Guéret qui sont des petites
villes de 14000 habitants 3000 4000
manifestants c'est beaucoup ça dit
quelque chose ça dit aussi beaucoup sa
dit surtout le caractère très multiforme
de cette mobilisation c'est à dire que
il y a évidemment les grands centres
urbains qui sont très mobilisés mais il
y a aussi ces petites villes les
sous-préfectures et
multi enfin oui quand c'est à la fois
géographique mais à la fois dans les
profils des gens qui participent
beaucoup entendu et c'est vrai je l'ai
vu dans les dans les rues de Paris
notamment des gens qui n'ont jamais
manifesté mais de toute génération c'est
à dire les jeunes les salariés mais
aussi des retraités puisque c'est un peu
la nouveauté et c'est un peu la mauvaise
nouvelle pour Emmanuel Macron c'est que
y compris maintenant les retraités sont
quand même majoritairement contre cette
réforme donc moi c'est ça qui me frappe
c'est effectivement
cette mobilisation de la France des
territoires ça il y a aussi qui qui est
pas sans lien avec
l'héritage des gilets jaunes qui étaient
des mobilisations au plus près des
territoires de France des ronds donc
c'est pas ça en lien ce que c'est aussi
des germes de cette mobilisation des
gilets jaunes que l'on voit resurgir à
travers la France qui se mobilise jusque
dans les plus petites villes de France
c'est c'est une nouvelle donne de cette
de ces mobilisations Nicolas qu'est-ce
que ça dit cette mobilisation dans des
villes moyennes dans des petites villes
dans des endroits où on n'avait pas vu
des manifestations depuis plusieurs
années c'est très illustratif de ce
phénomène de rejet de cette réforme qui
a rassemble comme vous l'avez dit Pierre
plusieurs générations on avait cru au
départ que il peut y avoir un conflit
entre les jeunes et les vieux pour
résumer avec des retraités qui
traditionnellement soutiennent ce type
de réformes parce qu'ils pensent que
c'est bon pour leur pouvoir d'achat que
ça préservera le niveau des pensions
même si c'est pas comme ça que c'est
construit en tout cas dans l'opinion
c'est l'image que les retraités ont
souvent de ce type de réforme là on voit
que c'est pas le cas il y a plutôt une
forme d'unité intergénérationnelle et
puis en fonction des des secteurs
d'activités aussi bon c'est bien sûr les
la fonction publique qui donne les gros
bataillons de retraités donc là on est
aussi dans des villes où il y a des
hôpitaux où il y a des fonctionnaires et
donc voilà il y a des gens qui qui sont
en capacité de se mobiliser peut-être
plus facilement que les salariés du
privé néanmoins on voit aussi dans les
études opinion que le secteur privé
aussi se sent directement concernés et
et participe de cette quasi
relatif consensus global contre cette
réforme aussi autre chose c'est cette
mobilisation dans les petites une simple
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce que c'est aussi la
traduction de Français qui se sent
abandonnés c'est dans des villes où les
services publics ont souvent disparu
est-ce que du coup il y a un risque la
colère prenne de l'ampleur au-delà de la
réforme le déclencheur de ce type de
manifestation c'est jamais un seul sujet
c'est à dire que si il y avait eu
uniquement la réforme des retraites
peut-être qu'il y aura eu des
mobilisations mais pas à ce niveau là
donc on le sait le panorama général il
est mauvais c'est une inflation qui est
très forte notamment sur les prix
alimentaires énormément d'inquiétudes et
puis on sort d'une période où
l'incertitude était aussi à son maximum
sur ce que pouvait être les perspectives
globales mais au niveau mondial donc on
a un contexte global vous avez raison
souligner que il y a souvent dans les
villes moyennes un ressenti qui est un
peu sourd qui est un peu qui s'exprime
pas forcément dans des manifestations
mais sur le fait que voilà il y a des
service public qui peuvent avoir disparu
des des commerces aussi qui ne sont plus
dans les centres-villes donc ce
sentiment d'être déclassé bon ça il est
connu depuis il date pas de la réforme
des retraites il est connu depuis
maintenant une quinzaine d'années il
nourrit de l'abstention il nourrit du
vote extrême et là il a
vraisemblablement nourri aussi des
matières c'est sûr alors soit sur la
journée d'hier le nombre de Français qui
sont descendus dans la rue a été plus
importants que le 19 janvier dernier
mais le nombre de grévistes a été
moindres est-ce que c'est quand même un
mauvais signal pour le monde syndical
alors c'est une c'est une vraie
interrogation c'est beaucoup posé la
question hier dans dans notre rédaction
et c'est vrai que
c'est pas ce qu'il faut retenir de la
journée d'hier quand même la
mobilisation a été c'est une des plus
grandes mobilisations de ces 30
dernières années quand même c'est pas
les chiffres des manifestants c'est les
chiffres de la préfecture de la
préfecture enfin de ministère de
l'Intérieur qui le dit près de d'un
million 200000 manifestants c'est des
chiffres jamais vu depuis près de 30 ans
donc c'est ça qu'il faut retenir après
effectivement sur l'état de la
mobilisation de la grève bon il faut
quand même se dire aussi on vit un
moment particulier ça a été dit
notamment par le journaliste que vous
avez interrogé tout à l'heure on vient
en particulier où les Français vivent
l'inflation il y a pas d'augmentation de
salaire
les gens sont de plus en plus dans la
précarité vivent difficilement de leur
propre travail donc faire un journée de
grève c'est extrêmement c'est presque
devenu un privilège ça coûte
excessivement cher on est sur des tarifs
de 100 à 150 euros par jour de grever
dans le budget par mois par mois si par
jour de grève je veux dire donc c'est
quand même un choix très compliqué donc
il est pas improbable chez les
fonctionnaires encore que chez les
fonctionnaires c'est possible mais dans
l'école c'est pas possible de prendre un
jour de congé mais il est possible que
certaines personnes se soient mis en
congé et ne se soit pas de déclaré en
grève pour pouvoir participer à ces
mobilisation la deuxième chose c'est que
les syndicats ont tenu compte aussi de
cette de cette chose là de que tout le
monde ne peut pas se mettre en grève
définitive ou en grève perlée à
plusieurs jours d'intervalle et donc
fait la proposition les syndicales
l'intersyndicale a fait la proposition
d'une manifestation d'une journée de
rassemblement national le samedi 7 dans
le samedi 11 février pardon voilà donc
voilà c'est une mobilisation qui cherche
on sent bien de toute façon je pense que
personne n'est naïf sur ce sujet là les
Français sont majoritairement aussi là
cette réforme les Français sont
majoritairement favorables à ce qui est
des mobilisations durables contre cette
réforme donc les Français ont envie de
s'associer d'une manière ou d'une autre
assez mobilisation que ce soit par la
grève que ce soit par les mobilisations
et peut-être plus encore si des
mobilisations plus surprises
interviennent dans les jours à venir
parce qu'on a vu la mobilisation dans la
Vienne et dans les Deux-Sèvres on va
voir cette fois comment s'est passé la
journée du côté de Saint-Etienne Anthony
verpillon de TL7 était au cœur de la
manifestation regarde son sujet
c'est pas parce qu'on a à l'arrêt qu'on
peut pas faire du bruit du bruit du prix
s'il vous plaît
ambiance de stade de foot avec drapeau
et fumigène au départ du cortège de la
guerre de Châteaucreux ce mardi matin et
chacun y va de sa revendication entre ce
qui sont presque résignés et ce qui
regrettent amèrement après coup en tout
cas toutes les générations se sont
côtoyées ce mardi matin à Saint-Étienne
Thomas Ismaël Marc et Sandrine ont
jusqu'à 20 ans d'écart mais les mêmes
revendications les deux plus anciens
s'inquiètent directement pour leur
avenir j'ai pas mal de soucis de santé
et je me vois pas
continuer jusqu'à 64 ans dans quel état
on va arriver je veux dire si c'est bien
sûr bien sûr on vit plus longtemps
maintenant mais dans quel état je me
vois difficilement être devant les
élèves devant une classe de d'élèves de
lycée professionnel et d'arriver
effectivement à avoir l'énergie
nécessaire pour les suivre les mobiliser
les faire travailler enfin moi
personnellement j'étais prêt même à
augmenter légèrement ma méthode
cotisation pourvu que les charges
patronales augmentent aussi Ismaël lui
est venu avec le fond car c'est avant
tout une aspiration pour le futur qu'il
souhaite défendre nous c'est plutôt le
modèle de société c'est-à-dire qu'on
veut toujours aller plus loin consommer
plus travailler plus je crois que le
l'air du temps elle est pas à ça quoi ce
qui ceux qui sont dans cette logique là
c'est c'est dépasser aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on veut du temps avec notre
famille avec nos enfants aujourd'hui on
sait que plus on consomme plus on
détruit la planète donc l'objectif c'est
de ralentir au contraire c'est
monstrueux pour pour nos enfants on va
leur laisser tellement on va leur
laisser quoi c'est ce qui nous inquiète
c'est pour ça qu'on vient en famille
enfin le plus jeune des quatre lui aussi
s'inquiète pour l'héritage qu'il subira
si cette réforme est adoptée notre
génération ne voudra pas travailler
jusqu'à 70 ans on voit aujourd'hui que
des chiffres comme l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé c'est les chiffres qui
n'augmentent pas autant que l'espérance
de vie on veut pas forcément à avoir
tout ce que faisait nos parents on voit
dans par exemple dans la médecine
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
médecins qui veulent travailler 35
heures et avoir une vie de famille à
côté plutôt que l'ancien modèle d'un
médecin qui bossait 70 heures qui
n'avait pas de vue à côté le texte de la
réforme des retraites est examinée
depuis lundi en commission il arrivera à
l'Assemblée le 6 février et voilà ce
sujet de telle tête à télévision locale
de la loi Nicolas on l'a vu il y a
plusieurs générations il y a plusieurs
catégories socioprofessionnelles et puis
il y a aussi cette question finalement
de la place du travail c'est aussi ça
qui motive les manifestants oui bien sûr
et c'est particulièrement frappant
d'entendre ce type d'arguments pour tout
raison la première c'est que
on entendait pas du tout le même chose
en 2010 alors qu'il y a eu le même
mouvement d'augmentation de l'âge légal
report de 60 à 62 ans sous Nicolas
Sarkozy on n'avait pas du tout ce type
de débat donc on n'est jamais les gens
dire à j'arriverai jamais à travailler
deux ans de plus bon donc là il y a
clairement pour l'exécutif c'est très
illustratif de sa défaite sur le terrain
argumentaire ou le passage à deux ans de
plus 62 64 ans ça passe pas du tout et
les gens ont trouvé cet argument là de
dire j'arriverai pas bon ça c'est quand
même enfin faut essayer vraiment une
défaite lourde pour le gouvernement
parce que à partir du moment où vous
l'avez à foule qui disent ça c'est plus
rien n'est possible politiquement son
image est totalement dégradée ensuite on
a des Français qui des françaises qui
vont dans la rue avoir ce type
d'expression mais on entend ça nulle
part ailleurs dans le monde c'est à dire
que quand on regarde les comparatifs sur
les âges de départ dans les voisins ce
qui se passe à l'étranger on va personne
ne tient ce type de discours qui a bien
particularité française autour de des
retraites et qui justifient sans doute
que il y a une réforme et peut-être pas
celle-là et puis le troisième point
c'est que aussi on est dans un contexte
par les de 2010 mais qui a radicalement
changé sur la perception du travail
puisque les enquêtes nous disent que
l'arbitrage entre travail et loisirs
c'est un verset où vous avez des
Français il y a quelques années qui
expliquaient que la place du travail
devait être au moins
suffisante pour pouvoir voilà avoir un
niveau de vie confortable et maintenant
c'est plutôt l'arbitrage en faveur des
loisirs qui l'emportent et on se dit bah
je préfère travailler moins peut-être
gagner moins mais avoir plus de temps
pour trouver un sens à ma vie si je
résume donc ça c'est aussi un contexte
pas seulement social mais aussi
sociologique qui fait que cette réforme
elle est particulièrement inaudible pour
les gens qu'on vient d'entendre et on va
voir justement la réponse du
gouvernement pierre avant de faire
réagir puisque ce matin deux ministres
en première ligne sur cette réforme se
sont exprimés on va les écouter Olivier
du socle et Gabriel Attal
la mobilisation est importante ça doit
nous amener à toujours continuer à
expliquer à essayer de convaincre nous
savons que cette réforme est nécessaire
elle est nécessaire parce que le système
ne tient pas aujourd'hui il est en
déficit il est en déficit dès 2023 il se
rend difficile de plus de 12 milliards
d'euros par an en 2027 et c'est presque
15 milliards en 2030 et donc c'est un
déficit qui va en s'accumulant en
s'aggravant parce que je dis c'est qu'il
est jamais trop tard pour se parler que
probablement que sur le point central de
cette réforme on ne tombera pas d'accord
mais enfin qu'on peut continuer à
l'enrichir ensemble moi je veux rappeler
qu'il y a eu des mois de concertation
avec la première ministre Elisabeth
borne avec mon collègue Olivier du soft
on était au départ à 65 ans on est passé
à 64 ans au départ la revalorisation des
petites retraites c'était que pour les
nouveaux retraités maintenant ça sera
aussi pour les retraités actuels on a
élargi la prise en compte de la
pénibilité on entend le gouvernement
est-ce qu'il voit hier c'est le fait
qu'il faut faire plus de pédagogie ils
disent on est toujours ouvert à la
discussion mais on a déjà fait des
efforts est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement entendu le
messager
non non j'ai pas du tout le sentiment
que le gouvernement entendu ils ont beau
répéter qu'ils sont dans la concertation
et la discussion ou notre équipe nous
parle jamais de négociation d'ailleurs
parce que en général un syndicat quand
il est en face d'un gouvernement il est
là pour négocier il est pas là pour
écouter la la parole du gouvernement en
tout cas pas que donc il est là pour
négocier donc oui certes il y a eu des
consultations des concertations des
consultations souvenez-vous l'époque de
le voir l'époque du ministre dédié à la
réforme des retraites tout ça c'est tout
oublié on est passé à une autre histoire
et le gouvernement s'entête si ce n'est
et devient obsédé à l'idée de faire
passer une réforme où tout le monde
personne ne veut le gouvernement dit on
a discuté avec les syndicats on a fait
des compromis sur la pénibilité on a
discuté avec les parlementaires on est
passé de 65 à 64 moi je ressens beaucoup
de sébrilité quand même dans les
interventions dans les dernières
interventions des ministres c'est-à-dire
quand le ministral explique aux Français
que il y a ceux qui travaillent pas qui
sont dans la rue contre ceux qui
travailleraient qui seraient pas dans la
rue enfin pardon mais ceux qui sont dans
la rue a priori ce sont des gens qui
perdent des jours de 10 jours de salaire
et qui travaillent et qui sont
profondément opposé à cette réforme donc
je trouve qu'il y a non seulement de la
fébrilité mais beaucoup d'arrogances
dans la manière dans l'attitude du
gouvernement quand j'entends la première
ministre hier expliquer que les
oppositions n'auraient pas de projet
alternatif mais là c'est pareil vraiment
c'est du mépris mais total pour ce que
c'est que le dialogue social si elle
considère que les syndicats viennent
dans son bureau sans projet sans
discussion avec leur propre base
militante c'est se moquer éperdument de
ce qu'est le dialogue social et de ce
que sont les syndicats et y compris des
politiques pardon mais il y a encore eu
des élections il y a très peu de temps
ça s'appelle les élections législatives
chacun est venu avec un projet politique
chacun est venu avec un projet sur la
question des retraites donc elle ne peut
pas dire la première ministre aux
Français regardez il y a que nous qui
avons des solutions personne d'autre
t'as une solution non il y a des
solutions qui sont sur la table mais il
faut que le gouvernement assume l'idée
de dire que ils veulent faire payer aux
Français les plus pauvres notamment les
cadeaux qu'ils ont fait au plus riche il
y a des propositions alternatives c'est
un débat d'économiste personne n'est
d'accord sur le quai sur les questions
tout le monde a des divergences sur la
manière dont on doit financer la
question des retraites c'est donc un
débat éminemment politique c'est un
choix de société je crois que potentiel
ont visiblement très majoritairement
très majoritairement tranchée contre ce
projet en tout cas est-ce que le
gouvernement a d'autres choix que de
répondre comme il a fait là il va être
obligé de trouver une solution parce que
ce qui est en jeu c'est pas uniquement
la réforme des retraites et pas
uniquement le financement à moyen terme
de des régimes c'est aussi l'image de
réformateur que va laisser Emmanuel
Macron et ça c'est dans son esprit
peut-être au moins aussi important que
la technique et donc il peut pas
continuer dans le scénario dans lequel
on est aujourd'hui avec l'idée que cette
réforme ce soit elle va passer parce que
techniquement et juridiquement ils ont
tous les moyens de tous les moyens
d'aller tous les moyens d'aller jusqu'au
bout pour discuter mais bon il y a des
parlementaire voilà oui bien sûr on est
bien sûr le scénario principal c'est
quand même celui-là et donc donc cette
réforme techniquement elle peut rentrer
dans en vigueur après qu'est-ce qui
reste de l'image du président de la
République qui aura certes réformé le
pays mais en le fracturant est-ce que
c'est ça qui veut de laisser dans
l'opinion on peut imaginer que non donc
on entend dans la majorité des
propositions des idées il faut qu'on
ouvre d'autres chantiers d'autres débats
en lien avec le travail la question du
travail et puis la réforme des retraites
bien sûr mais ouvrir d'autres
perspectives et avoir un terrain de
discussion et des avancées qui soient
sur d'autres thèmes mais qui permettent
de faire passer cette réforme des
retraites donc finalement un contexte
qu'elle aurait jamais dû quitter qui est
celui de du rapport au travail du
rapport au temps de vie et puis quand on
se lance dans ce type de réforme on voit
bien qu'il y a ça ouvre des tas de
tiroirs l'emploi des seniors la
pénibilité etc qui sont ben
manifestement de l'opinion pas du tout
traitée en tout cas pas bien donc le
gouvernement peut peut-être et voir des
nouvelles idées on entend ce matin les
propositions de réduction de temps de
travail la semaine de quatre jours des
expérimentations bon peut-être que ça
fait partie d'une stratégie qui vise à
Montreux français qui a pas que
travailler plus longtemps qui qui compte
pour eux mais en tout cas politiquement
il peut pas rester au statu quo actuel
avec une opinion totalement braquée des
manifestations de plus en plus
nombreuses dont toutes les rues de
France c'est une situation politique qui
est qui brise peut-être aussi le privé
de majorité puisqu'on voit de plus en
plus de députés y compris à droite se
dire bah finalement les Français sont
tellement contre que Ben peut-être pas
voter pour oui le gouvernement a compris
qu'il avait perdu la bataille de
l'opinion c'est une certitude il vient
de comprendre qu'il avait perdu la
bataille de la rue les syndicats ont
fait la démonstration de force donc il
va engager la bataille parlementaire
c'est son seul point de de c'est sa
seule sortie mais ce que n'a pas encore
compris le gouvernement c'est qu'on est
au tout début de la mobilisation sociale
je relisais hier les travaux de Sophie
Berrou qui a une
historienne de du mouvement social et je
refaisait le le parcours des
mobilisations de 95 bon bah ça démarre
encore beaucoup plus petitement en tout
cas en terme de nombre de mobilisation
au tout début de la mobilisation et puis
ça prend petit à petit et les secteurs
entiers qui se mettent en grève puis les
étudiants rentrent dans la danse là
encore les jeunes la jeunesse était très
nombreuse hier dans la rue de Paris en
tout cas pour ce que j'en ai vu mais les
étudiants les si tout ça se met en
mobilisation ça va un tout petit peu
changer la donne pour le gouvernement
Alain Juppé en 95 disait si mon si les
mobilisations dépassent les 2 millions
mon gouvernement dit survivra pas bon
bah il n'a pas survécu parce qu'il a
renoncé à cette réforme là on est à 2
millions 9 selon le syndicat un million
deux selon la police je crois que le
gouvernement ferait bien entendre ce qui
se passe dans la rue et que il faudrait
pas qu'Emmanuel Macron parce que moi je
sais que tout le monde a passé de
lecture là mais Emmanuel Macron a
renoncé que deux fois depuis qu'il est
président de la République une fois
c'était Notre Dame des Landes il a
renoncé à son projet pour lequel il
avait été élu il avait dit qu'il le
ferait des violences ont fait qu'il a
renoncé à ce projet et la deuxième fois
c'était les gilets jaunes au lendemain
de ces mobilisations qui avaient tant
heurté l'opinion publique mais aussi
plus largement le monde parce que il y
avait eu beaucoup d'images qui avaient
circuler très vers le monde savait pas
beaucoup plu à Emmanuel Macron autour de
l'acte de Triomphe donc faudrait pas que
ce mouvement converge en tout cas aille
vers des violences
possibles si ça s'enlise pour que ça
risque ça risque qu'il prend oui il
prend le risque là de mettre la France à
feu à sens si cette mobilisation
dans la durée et le calendrier
parlementaire est quand même assez long
là
et de la bataille parlementaire on va
voir ce qui s'est passé hier à
l'Assemblée Marion parce que vous allez
nous raconter ça il y a eu un des
tensions autour de la motion
référendaire à raconter nous oui alors
petite explication de texte pour
commencer la motion réfère inverse et
cette disposition qui permet d'organiser
donc un référendum sur certains projets
de loi et l'opposition avait décidé de
s'en saisir pour la réforme des
retraites le 23 janvier dernier le
président du groupe communiste André
Chassagne dépose au nom de la nuit UPS
une motion signée par 98 députés et le
lendemain le 24 janvier Marine Le Pen en
dépose une également signée par 60
députés rassemblement national et hier
matin pour savoir laquelle de ces deux
motions sera débattue dans l'hémicycle
le 6 février prochain la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé de les tirer au sort
et c'est la motion du rassemblement
national qui est sortie colère dans les
rangs de la nupaisse pour qui cette
décision va à l'encontre du règlement
mais justement le règlement de l'ASSE
de la réforme des retraites ne soient
pas examinés en assemblée parce que nous
demandions un référendum et réponse de
Marine Le Pen il n'y a pas de polémique
le tirage au sort vient régler justement
le vide juridique
c'est un état naturel pour eux d'être en
permanence en colère et plein de haine
il y a des règles
les règles ont été appliquées le
règlement intérieur a été analysé il y a
donc eu un tirage au sort et ils peuvent
s'agacer contre la chance peut-être mais
contre personne d'autre et un peu plus
tard dans la journée dans un courrier
signé des quatre présidents de groupes
de la Nupe et bien ils ont exigé que la
nihilation tirage au sort soit annulé
oui voici ce qui est écrit le simple
fait qu'il y ait été proposé un tirage
au sort pour départager de motions
référendaires est une décision
arbitraire qui ne repose sur aucune
disposition de notre règlement si cette
disposition est maintenue plusieurs
responsables de la nupes comme André
Chasset nous Cyriel châtelain ont
indiqué qu'il ne voterait pas la motion
du rassemblement national ce projet de
référendum donc sur la réforme des
retraites a du pont dans l'aile et on le
voit Nicolas une histoire d'articles
d'un règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
a pris des proportions politiques
énormes est-ce que ça illustre de la
attention parlementaire alors que le
texte n'est même pas encore dans
l'hémicycle oui bien sûr ça illustre les
états d'esprit dans lequel peuvent être
certaines oppositions vis-à-vis de
retraite et puis avec devant eux la
perspective quand même de prendre la
lumière pendant une dizaine ou une
vingtaine de jours à l'Assemblée et bon
évidemment ça ça crée une crise passion
qu'on vient d'entendre et il faut quand
même remettre les choses un peu à leur
place cette notion référendaire elle a
aucune chance d'être adoptée donc que
vous soyez rassemblement national ou LFI
vous allez perdre de façon dans
l'hémicycle pour à ce moment-là donc on
est dans un jeu qui a un jeu
d'obstruction et de savoir qui fera la
meilleure obstruction finalement c'est
ça que ça raconte l'émotion infernale
n'a jamais eu une seule sur la Cinquième
République qui est allée jusqu'au bout
parce qu'on rappelle quand même que pour
aller jusqu'au bout ça veut dire qu'elle
soit votée aussi au Sénat puis accepter
par le Président de la République donc
c'est ça que dit la Constitution on voit
bien que là c'était totalement voué à
chaque et ça illustre une fois de plus
le fait que c'est juste une démarche
tactique pour faire de l'obstruction je
trouve que c'est assez déplorable pour
la démocratie parce que ça donne une
image du Parlement qui est totalement
délétère et puis rappelons que si
vraiment ces oppositions souhaitent qui
a référendum qui demande aux Français de
se prononcer pour ou contre un projet de
loi ou une proposition de loi plutôt sur
les retraites à ce moment-là il existe
aussi la voix du référendum d'initiative
partagée on n'a pas entendu ni le RN ni
la nups dire qu'ils allaient engager
dans cette voie qui demande cueillez un
10% pardon du des électeurs qui le
valide pierre pas tout à fait d'accord
non pas tout à fait d'accord parce que
d'abord on ne sait pas ce qui aurait pu
donner cette motion référendum si elle
avait été déposée par la gauche parce
que la droite est déjà bien embêtée de
savoir ce qu'elle va faire si elle faut
voter ou pas voter cette cette réforme
donc à la limite confier l'idée d'une
acceptation de cette réforme aux
Français pour certains d'entre eux y
compris d'ailleurs parmi les gens de la
majorité aurait pu se dire que c'est
peut-être la moins mauvaise des
solutions que de passer par avoir
référendum vous avez raison c'est de
toute façon c'est Emmanuel Macron qui me
finait choisi quand même il y a une
majorité à l'assemblée de moi ce qui me
frappe et ce que je trouve vraiment mais
scandaleux dans cette histoire vraiment
hier je suis tombé de ma chaise quand
j'ai appris la nouvelle parce que je
trouve que on a là un président qui n'a
jamais autant fait qu'il n'a jamais
autant servi de tremplin à l'extrême
droite c'est à dire que qu'est-ce qu'il
fait en acceptant pas la motion
référendaire de la gauche d'abord c'est
la plus légitime non mais d'abord
conférence d'abord
c'est la plus légitime c'est la nups qui
a déposé la motion référendaire la
première et si en plus on prend en
compte la notion des référendaires
déposés par le rassemblement national
elle est signée par beaucoup moins de
parlementaires donc la logique aurait
voulu qu'on accepte la motion
référendaire de la nups qui a d'ailleurs
été acceptée et qu'on décide que plus
personne ne pouvait déposer puisqu'elle
est la première avait déjà été déposée
par un nombre suffisant de députés le
fait qu'on décide comme ça sur un coup
de hasard qu'on va faire un tirage au
sort sans pondération c'est pas sans
pondération pardon mais sans pondération
comme ça que ça s'est passé oui ou non
c'est pas décidé au hasard c'est une
conférence des présidents
la majorité présidentielle qui est donc
décidé de faire ça au tirage au sort
sans pondération pardon centre des
ration c'est quand même le principe
c'est qu'il faut une pondération parce
qu'il y a quand même plus de députés du
peste que des députés de rassemblement
national donc le gouvernement fait le
choix de faire sans pondération donnant
une majeure enfin un avantage non parce
que c'est quand même le tirage au sort
mais un avantage quand même si à la
rationnelle alors qu'il aurait déjà du
côté de la de la nups ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça fait quand même
beaucoup du côté de la majorité
présidentielle où on se sert où on crée
des alliances de circonstances avec le
rassemblement national pour pouvoir s'en
sortir par le haut parce que personne ne
votera la voiture la motion du
rassemblement national c'est une
évidence à gauche donc ça veut dire que
bon bah on remet les rassemblement
national au cœur du dispositif c'est eux
qui vont avoir la priorité à l'Assemblée
nationale de ce débat et de l'exposition
de de cette motion référendaire alors
même que le rassemblement national
n'existe pas dans les commissions des
affaires sociales ce n'est pas présent
dans la rue d'abord parce que personne
n'en veut et aujourd'hui manuel Macron
remet le rassemblement national au cœur
de l'actualité politique je trouve ça
vraiment mais scandaleux et la
conclusion 20 secondes
j'insiste juste sur le déroulement des
faits le déroulement effet vous dites
Emmanuel Macron mais c'est la conférence
des présidents il n'était pas présent
dans cette réunion et ensuite il y a un
tirage au sort effectivement si la pièce
était tombée de l'autre côté il y aurait
pas d'histoire en faisant semblablement
ou peut-être qu'on aura entendu
la pondération c'est quand même un
élément important de ce tirage au sort
de la semaine prochaine on pourrait
invitera évidemment on va suivre tout ça
puisque le texte arrive lundi dans
l'hémicycle on va
[Musique]